alors que la crise sanitaire se traduit
par des incertitudes exceptionnellement
élevé tant sur le plan macroéconomique
que budgétaire l'avis du haut conseil
est important pour éclairer la
représentation nationale sur l'évolution
de nos finances publiques et la
sincérité du projet de loi de finances
je voudrais vous rappeler mes chers
collègues que notre audition fait
l'objet d'une retransmission sur le site
internet du sénat et je laisse donc sans
plus attendre la parole à pierre
moscovici premier président de la cour
des comptes et à ce titre président du
haut conseil des finances publiques bien
vous la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur général nous dames et
messieurs les sénateurs
merci de m'avoir invité devant votre
commission malgré en effet les
circonstances que je connais du
renouvellement sénatorial en tant que
président du conseil des finances
publiques pour vous présenter les
principales conclusions de notre avis
relatif au projet de loi de finances et
de financement de la sécurité sociale
pour l'année 2000 21
c'est la deuxième fois je crois que je
viens devant vous en tant que président
du haut conseil
mais aussi comme président de la cour
des comptes à l'occasion de ma première
audition qui a eu lieu une semaine après
ma nomination qui était relative au
troisième collectif budgétaire
je vous avais présenté mon attachement
sincère ou au conseil une institution
que j'ai porté sur les fonts baptismaux
en 2012 alors j'étais mise de l'économie
et des finances j'avais aussi souligné
en faisant écho à cette tendance
personnel
la double orientation la fois nationale
et européenne du haut conseil
le conseil comme vous le savez est
chargé de veiller à la sincérité des
prévisions macroéconomiques et les
finances publiques établi par le
gouvernement français mais il a aussi un
regard européen puisqu'il est compétent
pour apprécier la cohérence la
trajectoire de finances publiques au
regard de nos engagements européens et
des règles en vigueur en la matière
je vous avais d'ailleurs indiqué mme on
souhaite approfondir les relations entre
cet organisme et le parlement je tiens
aujourd'hui à vous le redire avec
conviction éclairer le législateur est
au coeur de la mission du haut conseil
je pense que pour vous parlementaire
disposer d'un tiers de confiance
indépendant est effectivement nécessaire
à la qualité est la sincérité des
prévisions gouvernementales sur lesquels
sont établis les textes financiers qui
vous sont soumis assurer cette mission
suppose que le mandat et les moyens
confié au conseil soit adapté cet enjeu
démocratique mais aussi aux enjeux de
finances publiques que nous impose la
crise sanitaire et économique que nous
traversons
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir dans
quelques instants en conclusion de mon
propos en partageant avec vous certaine
réflexion sur la modernisation de la
gouvernance des finances publiques
je peux être plus longue d'entre eux
pointent indiqué jean vient la saisine
du haut conseil d'abord quelques mots
sur le contexte international
dans la continuité du troisième plf
rectificatif le pellec pour 2021 et
marquer évidemment par le choc
économique très grande ampleur qui a
touché l'économie mondiale au premier
semestre 2020 en raison de la crise
sanitaire
la chute de l'activité du fait de
l'épidémie des mesures de restrictions
sanitaires présente en fait le même
profil dans la plupart des économies du
monde
ce n'est pas un v ça valide et conjugue
fortement et qu'on remonte d'un coup ce
n'est pas un w en tout cas pas à ce
stade qui serait une sorte de double
plongeon mais c'est bel et bien une
racine carrée vous la voyez dessiner ici
cette image la racine carrée signifie
que le pic mondial s'est très nettement
repliés au premier semestre avant de
connaître un rebond très vigoureux mais
incomplet au cours du second et que le
retour à la normale de l'activité vous
voyez le départ c'est la norme 2019
devrait selon l'ensemble des prévisions
être lent les économies enregistre bien
sûr un recul un rebond de l'activité de
l'ampleur et de temporalité
diverses mais disons que comme s'est
montrée ici le profil d'ensemble est
très largement partagée au niveau
mondial en tout cas dans les grandes
économies industrialisées occidentales
en particulier l'activité de la zone
euro se serait située près de 15 % en
dessous de son niveau d'avant crise
selon le consensus des prévisionnistes
mais vous le savez le haut conseil avant
d'établir son ami consultent tous les
prévisionnistes français cet écart
devrait se résorber progressivement mais
l'activité dans son ensemble ne
retrouvera son niveau d'avant crise
disons qu'elle a mis 2022
d'après les dernières données
disponibles sur rebond l'économie
mondiale ne serait ainsi que partiel
aujourd'hui plusieurs indicateurs
signalent effectivement depuis juillet
que le rattrapage qui était très fort au
début de l'été commence déjà à
s'essouffler notamment freiné par
certains secteurs de service comme le
transport aérien l'hôtellerie la
restauration bien sûr pour lesquels les
restrictions d'origine sanitaire perdure
voire s'aggravent les perspectives de
croissance du mondial reste par ailleurs
soumise aux incertitudes qui entourent
l'évolution des conditions sanitaires
les incertitudes sur la maîtrise de
l'économie nous savons tous comme sur le
développement d'un vaccin demeure
exceptionnellement élevé ce qui
fragilise incontestablement l'exercice
des prévisions macro économique et de
finances publiques et donc croyez que en
vous présentant cet avis nous sommes
dans la modestie que qu'impose cette
situation d'incertitude comme les autres
ce contexte général est en pause et je
vais désormais vous présenter les trois
principaux messages du haut conseil le
premier porte sur les prévisions macro
économique et de finances publiques
gouvernement que nous estimons c'est le
mot qu'il faut retenir plausible le
second tient à la nécessité absolue pour
nous d'adopter le plus tôt possible et
le plus tôt possible pour nous c'est dès
le printemps 2021 une nouvelle loi de
programmation des finances publiques
j'utilise un deuxième mot l'actuelle
étant évidemment caduque donc plausible
est caduque
enfin le dernier trait à la
soutenabilité de là
dette publique qui doit constituer la
boussole de la stratégie de finances
publiques de la france et qu'ils
appellent troisième mot une grande
vigilance
voilà les trois axes de notre
présentation d'abord le scénario macro
et kim du gouvernement subit à l'image
la plupart de nos partenaires une
évolution racine carrée pour 2020 le
gouvernement prévoit en conséquence à
recul depuis français de 10% en volume
un chiffre en légère amélioration par
rapport à la prévision du troisième et
lfr pour 2020 qui était à 11%
la prévision de fin mai avait d'ailleurs
été jugée prudente par le haut conseil
nous pensions qu'il y avait un certain
nombre de facteurs qui permettrait de
limiter la récession pour 2020 le
gouvernement prévoir rebond de
l'activité de 8%
le haut conseil considère que le
scénario macro qu'humide ensemble à
l'horizon 2021 donc cumulant 2020 2021
est plausible ce qualificatif de
plausible nous l'utilisons pour les
prévisions d'activité économique nos
sites d'inflation d'emploi de masse
salariale en 2021
l'activité s'établirait en fin de
période à 2 7% en dessous de son niveau
de 2010 9 qui est un montant proche des
autres prévisions disponibles
ça dépendra en tout état de cause
étroitement de l'évolution de la
situation sanitaire
mais il je vais introduire une nuance
tout de suite que ce qui est que si nous
estimons que le scénario macro et quid
ensemble est plausible d'ici 2021
nous avons un regard un tout petit peu
différente ce doublement sur la
chronique annuel pour 2020 nous
considérons que sauf aggravation marquée
de la situation sanitaire d'ici la fin
d'année qui n'est pas à exclure qui
compromettrait une reprise du travail
dans le pays
c'est bien de cette nature-là dont il
s'agit la prévision d'activité prudent
c'est à dire que le recul du pib devrait
être encore un peu moins que prévu
disons que le consensus des
prévisionnistes est plus autour de 9%
que de 10% pour 2021 al'inverse
l'ampleur du rebond pour être plus
limité qu'attendu par le plf pour 2021
pourquoi c'est parce que ce rebond
repose sur l'hypothèse forte
l'amélioration de la situation sanitaire
tout au long de l'année 2000 21 qui
n'est pas certaine mais aussi sur
l'hypothèse que le qualifiant d'
volontariste d'un effet important des
mesures de du plan de relance sur la
croissance ou le mans l'estiment à 1,1
pour cent du pib ce qui s'ajouterait
notamment aux effets attendus des plans
de relance chez nos partenaires
disons que voilà il ya là peut-être une
nuance avec le gouvernement par exemple
nous pensons que l'effet du plan de
relance sur l'investissement public
local que le sénat connaît bien pour
être un peu moins fort en 2021 que prévu
par la loi de finances pourquoi en
raison de délais inhérents à
l'instruction de dossiers
d'investissement et aussi du niveau déjà
élevé des capacités de production du
secteur du bâtiment donc nous pourrions
avoir
la petit tassement une petite difficulté
mise en oeuvre du plan de relance au
niveau local sur le fondement de ces
hypothèses économiques le gouvernement
de prévoir un niveau de déficit
absolument inédit je le souligne depuis
plus de 70 ans
il s'établirait à 10 2% du pib en 2020
puis 6 7% du pib en 2021 sur les
prévisions qui en fait sont assez
proches de celles que le gouvernement
vous a présenté l'été dernier lors du
débat d'orientation des finances
publiques par rapport au rapport
préparatoire ce débat le plf prévoit une
seule public en amélioration de 1,2
point en 2020 mais symétriquement une
dégradation de 1,2 point en 2021
cette prévision prend en compte la
révision des hypothèses macroéconomiques
et de nouvelles mesures de soutien à
l'activité
décidée dans le cadre du plan de relance
là encore le conseil estime que le seul
public nominal prévu pour 2020 et 2021
être atteignable même si là encore il ya
des incertitudes qui entourent les
conditions sanitaires que les évolutions
macro et au delà du déterminant
sanitaires nous sommes attachés à
identifier les principaux risques qui
affecte les prévisions de recettes et
dépenses sur la base d'informations
disposons sur les prélèvements
obligatoires
nous estimons ces prévisions cohérente
avec le scénario macroéconomique nous
relevons que le gouvernement fait
l'hypothèse que les exonérations
temporaires de cotisations pour les
entreprises des secteurs les plus
touchés par la crise sanitaire ne seront
pas prolongés
en 2021 si cette hypothèse ne se
vérifier pas à se voiler recettes
publiques seraient dégradées s'agissant
des prévisions de dépenses publiques que
nous estimons vraisemblable il ya des
risques comme on dit à la hausse comme à
la baisse
du côté baissier la mise en oeuvre des
investissements prévus dans le cadre du
plan de relance pourrait plus lente
qu'attendu ce qui se traduirait par un
report de dépenses sur 2022 et sur les
années ultérieures par la charge
d'intérêt pour être un peu moins élevé
ça c'est traditionnel que dans la
prévision d'ubs élèves pour 2021 du fait
d' hypothèse de taux d'intérêt qui sont
comme à l'accoutumée relativement
conservatrice du côté haussier relevons
à risque sur le niveau attendu des
dépenses de santé
le plf pour 2010 atteint prévoit
effectivement une enveloppe de 4 3
milliards d'euros pour faire face à la
crise sanitaire en 2021 contre des
dépenses qui sont actuellement estimé à
10,1 milliards pour 2020 par exemple
dépenses associées à une éventuelle
campagne de vaccination pourrait se
révéler supérieure à celles qui sont
prévues par le plfss 2009 t1 de 1,5
milliard d'euros
en dépit de ces aléas le conseil
estiment dans l'ensemble que les
prévisions de finances publiques sont
atteignables donc pas irréaliste j'en
viens au second message porté par cet
avis du haut conseil qui suit n'a
nécessité d'adopter une nouvelle loi de
programmation des finances publiques
pourquoi parce que qu'il s'agisse du
scénario macro game sur les finances
publiques ou de finances publiques
elles-mêmes la lpfp du 22 janvier 2018
est définitivement caduque
pourquoi d'abord parce que l'estimation
du pib potentiel retenu par cette loi
qui a été adopté deux ans avant la crise
obsolète
l'ampleur du choc subi par l'économie
française devrait avoir nous le savons
tous à un impact durable sur l'appareil
productif sous l'effet notamment du
recul de l'investissement dans les
documents qui ont été fournis
au conseil nous on considère d'ores et
déjà qu'une niveau du pipe potentiels
devraient être ré habite révisé à la
baisse de 1,5 point en 2020 puis de plus
de 2 points en 2021 par rapport aux
hypothèses de notre programmation
plus généralement et ce n'est pas une
critique
la tra joie financière de notre
programmation n'anticipait évidemment
pas le choc sur les finances publiques
que nous observons en 2020 et de
constateront encore en 2021
souvenons nous que la loi de
programmation prévoyait un déficit
public égal à 1,5 point de pivot 2020 et
0,9 en 2021
des prévisions qui sont bien éloignées
de celles présentées par le plf pour
la difficulté c'est que bien que caduque
cette loi de programmation constitue aux
termes de la loi organique de 2012 que
je connais bien je les fait voter par le
parlement quand j'étais mis les finances
la référence pour le plf qui vous est
soumis aussi pour l'exercice du mandat
les au conseil également d'ailleurs pour
la commission européenne et ce à double
titre d'abord le concept doit s'appuyer
sur la croissance potentielle tel
qu'établi par leur programmation en
vigueur même si ça n'a plus aucun sens
le solde structurel est ainsi calculé
dans le plf pour 2021 avec la même
hypothèse de croissance potentielle
clown programmation même si c'est une
hypothèse qui n'est absolument plus
pertinentes ainsi la révision à la
baisse de la croissance potentielle
telle qu'estimée actuellement par le
gouvernement conduira à croître de plus
d'un point en 2021 le déficit structurel
et d'autre part c'est le deuxième
facteur le haut conseil doit comparer la
trajectoire financière prévu par le plf
celle de notre programmation
à cet égard le conseil constate que
l'écart de sol structurelles prévues en
2021 par rapport à la loi de
programmation de 2008 s'élève à moins de
4 points de pib ce qui est quand même un
écart important au sens de la loi
organique décembre 2012
le solde structurel présenté par le
gouvernement se dégraderait ainsi de
quatre points entre 2019 et 2021 et
s'établir à -3 6 % de fibres 2021
ce qui est très loin de l'objectif de
déficit structurel d'au moins 1,2 point
fixée par la loi de programmation
conclusion me semble-t-il logique et je
la soumet aux parlementaires que vous
êtes puisque les anciens repères
économiques et financiers sont devenus
inadaptés le haut conseil estime tout à
fait nécessaire d'en changer
aussitôt que possible qu'est ce que ça
veut dire aussi tôt que possible
c'est ne pas attendre que la crise
économique ou sociale soit derrière nous
peut-être même pas la crise sanitaire
simplement que la situation se soit
stabilisée et que l'horizon soit plus
lisible
au total le haut conseil avec le
gouvernement a présenté dès le printemps
2021 une nouvelle loi de programmation
des finances publiques qui permettra
d'établir une stratégie de finances
publiques de moyen terme qui fixera
notamment une nouvelle trajectoire
d'évolution du pib du pipe potentiels
ainsi que des finances publiques
confirmant la organique 2012
ça nous permettra aux uns et aux autres
de fonder notre appréciation sur des
critères qui correspondent beaucoup plus
à la réalité d'aujourd'hui qu'à celle
d'hier que la crise rend totalement
caduque avant de conclure je vous livre
le troisième message principal porté par
l'avis du haut conseil c'est celui sur
la soutenabilité de la dette selon là le
sénat du gouvernement la dette publique
s'élèvera à 117 qu'une 5 points de pib
en 2020 ce qui est tout de même une
hausse de près de 20 points par rapport
à la loi de finances initiale pour 2020
le ratio des publics reculerait ensuite
en 2021 mais très légèrement à 116,2
points cette perspective d'une baisse
limitée du ratio dette publique est lié
au très fort rebond du pib attendue par
le gouvernement les fragiles et elle
pourrait être remise en cause même si le
groupe dont l'activité était moins en
tout état de cause
constatons que la tête va connaître une
augmentation massive par rapport à la
situation d'avant crise
ce qui résulte à la fois du choc
économique inédit mais aussi de la
réponse budgétaire à porter pour y faire
face qui est tout aussi massive le ratio
de dette publique s'établirait ainsi en
2021 18.6 brute dessus de son niveau
d'avant crise et 22 points de pipe au
dessus de celui qui est prévu par la loi
de programmation
cette évolution n'intervient pas dans un
ciel serein puisqu'elle arrive après une
décennie quasi ininterrompues de hausse
de la dette
or le contexte de croissance potentielle
à faiblir en plus difficile
réduction du déficit conclusion pour
nous la soutenabilité à moyen terme de
la dette publique constitue un enjeu
central la stratégie financière de la
france
elle appelle à cet égard le plus grande
vigilance je sais que chez les
économistes comme chez les politiques
commencent à naître des débats et si on
annulait la dette
bonjour les épargnants si on monétiser
totalement la dette la dette la banque
centrale on prend déjà une bonne part
n'ira pas je crois jusqu'à une
monétisation absolue et les textes ne
permettent pas si on mutualiser la dette
est bien là comment ça il y aura un
début de mutualisation de la dette avec
le plan européen de relance mais ne
pensons pas que nous soyons à ce stade
conclusion nous retrouverons toujours un
la dette sur notre chemin un jour et
c'est un fardeau qui pèse sur les
générations futures une dette fini par
être remboursés nous avons rendez vous
avec elle c'est pour ça que nous sommes
sur ce message vis je termine en
partageant et vous quelques réflexions
sur la gouvernance des finances
publiques est particulièrement pardonnez
moi de plaider chapelle sur le mandat du
haut conseil la crise qui a touché la
france et le monde entier se traduit par
un choc massif sur les finances
publiques et notamment sur l'encours de
la dette publique je viens de le dire
au regard de cette situation je suis
persuadé qu'une refondation de la
stratégie financière est indispensable
pour assurer la soutenabilité de la
dette publique est la meilleur usage des
deniers publics
la cour des comptes s'est d'ailleurs
exprimé là dessus dans son rapport sur
la situation et les perspectives des
finances publiques publié en juin
dernier que j'ai présentée devant pour
faire respecter mettre en oeuvre cette
stratégie il faut un renforcement de la
gouvernance financière
je vous rappelle qu'en 2012 à la suite
de la crise financière de 2008 puis
suite de la crise des dettes souveraines
dans la zone euro
la gouvernance française et européenne
et financier qui avaient été refondé
pour éviter que les difficultés alors
rencontré ne se reproduise à venir
dans le prolongement du traité de
stabilité coordination et gouvernance on
appelle t scg la loi organique 2012
avait conséquence introduire le droit
français un ensemble de dispositifs
yves qui vise à favoriser une maîtrise
durable des finances publiques et
notamment elle avait fondé le haut
conseil des finances publiques après le
choc que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
qui je répète totalement inédit depuis
la seconde guerre mondiale il apparaît
nécessaire de compléter pas de revisiter
totalement l architecture élaboré en
2011 pour franchir une nouvelle étape
dans l'amélioration du pilotage des
finances publiques en france
la cour des comptes doit s'exprimer
là-dessus à l'automne mon propos n'est
pas d'anticiper ici sur un rapport qui
vous sera présenté
mais de vous dire avec ma casquette de
président du conseil
ce que j'en pense depuis sa création
notre jeune institution budgétaire
indépendante à contribuer à
l'amélioration du réalisme des
hypothèses macroéconomiques
c'est un constat qui étayé à chaque fois
je crois par des analyses économiques
que quelles que soient vos sensibilités
vous reconnaîtrez comme de très grande
qualité et bien sûr réaliser de manière
indépendante par le conseil toutefois
notre mandat et j insiste
significativement plus réduit que celui
nos homologues européens
comme nos moyens sont beaucoup plus
réduits que ceux de nos homologues
européens et c'est insuffisant à mes
yeux pour assurer la surveillance
indépendant de la trajectoire finances
publiques et éclairer les autorités et
les citoyens et les parlementaires sur
les risques liés à la situation de nos
finances publiques nous avons maintenant
échanger des questions et des réponses
je ne pourrais vous répondre que dans le
cadre du mandat qui veut bien
et donc je serais frustré je vais vous
frustré je pense que nous pourrions
faire beaucoup plus un première limite
je vais citer trois limites
la première c'est que la loi organique
de 2012 n'a pas formellement confié au
scfp la mission d'apprécier le réalisme
des prévisions de finances publiques il
s'agit des recettes des dépenses et du
déficit public dans l'exercice de son
mandat actuel ne pouvons pas faire
abstraction de ces du conte
considération il faut réellement l'objet
de développements de notre avis mais
notre analyse reste limité dans sa
portée par une loi organique
deuxième limite le crochet n'est pas non
plus compétent pour examiner le réaliste
de l'émulation de l'impact financier ou
socio économiques des mesures quand bien
même
celui-ci ou celle-ci sera déterminante
pour apprécier le réaliste la
trajectoire finances publiques si vous
me demandez ce que je pense de ceci ou
de cela de tel ou telle mesure
je ne vous répondrai pas car ce ne
serait qu'une réponse personnelle n'est
pas une réponse au sens du haut conseil
alors qu'avec un monde un peu plus
élargie
je pourrais vous répondre non pas à
partir d'un jugement mais à partir d'une
évaluation précise des choses troisième
limite et ce sera dernier exemple s'en
câlisse tu sois pourtant exhaustive
le mécanisme de correction ex post n'a
pas fait preuve de son efficacité
il a été créé par la loi organique 2012
mais son déclenchement par le conseil en
cas d'écart significatif après jour de
solde structurel est beaucoup trop
tardif parce qu'il intervient seulement
une fois les quatre elles soient
constatés et ne semblent pas permettre
d'assurer le plein respect des
trajectoires financière programmée au
regard de ses limites et de l'enjeu
central que constitue la soutenabilité
des trajectoires de dette publique
il me semble que des ajustements de la
cohérence de finances publiques serait
donc à mes yeux nécessaire j'ai demandé
au rapporteur général du haut conseil
eric dubois qui hélas de réfléchir aux
évolutions souhaitables du mandat de
notre institution budgétaire
indépendante dans une logique de
transparence de nos travaux mais aussi
de rénovation de la gouvernance le
rapport qui n'aura toi le town où sera
transmis est rendue bien sûr public
je pense que ça appelle un toilettage le
wat 2012 encore une fois limité mais
significatif et quand je compare là je
vais parler une seconde de mon
expérience me regarde pas ces deux
commissaires européens je vois que
l'institution française c'est peut-être
qu'il ya une tradition est tout à fait
indépendante mais c'est quand même celle
qui a le mandat et les moyens les plus
faibles qu'à jeudi un dernier mot sur
les moyens qu'il faut adapter ses moyens
aux nouveaux enjeux
d'ailleurs le pelleve pour 2021 prévoir
un accroissement très significatif des
moyens humains du haut conseil
je m'en réjouis si c'est confirmé dans
l'europe finance permettra de renforcer
dès le début des prochaines l'année
prochaine notre expertise économique
notre capacité analyse au service des
citoyens
et ça passe d'abord services du
parlement
mais je reviendrai devant vous car je
suis têtu avec ses propositions qui je
pense sont dans l'intérêt général
d'avoir encore une fois un tiers de
confiance qu'à part une indépendance et
une expertise tout à fait renforcée avec
des moyens adaptés
voilà mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs les quelques réflexions finale
que je voudrais partager avec vous et
après vous avoir remercié votre
attention je suis évidemment à votre
disposition pour répondre à vos
questions dans la limite du mandat il en
concert
merci monsieur le président et nous
avons entendu je vais inviter le
rapporteur général à nous faire part de
ces questions sur ce sujet merci
surveillants mes chers collègues très
heureux de vous retrouver sur président
du haut conseil
vous êtes dans le cas de notre mandat
mais je vois que vous perdez pas tout à
fait le sens de la vie parlementaire
parce que vous avez déjà quelques
messages sur les moyens du haut conseil
pour le plf donc on a bien compris
donc voilà que évident de moyens et donc
on a bien compris votre invitation à
voter cette augmentation des moyens du
haut conseil
je vais dire nous sommes presque très
admiratif de la capacité du haut conseil
à émettre un avis en ce moment parce que
alors j'avais lors de la dernière
édition on avait dit j'aime citer le
sous titre du soulier de satin de paul
claudel en disant que le pire n'était
pas toujours sur le moment j'avais dire
le meilleur n'est pas toujours sûr non
plus haut de cinq semaines dans une
grande période d'incertitude est donc en
mesure ne mesurons tous le hac modestie
la difficulté de l'exercice consiste à
donner un avis sur ce plf est sûre ce
plfss pour 2021
en effet les a sortis de ces
incertitudes sont extrêmement nombreuses
je ne parlerais évidemment pas de
l'évolution du contexte sanitaire je
n'ai aucune compétence en revanche la
première question portera sur l'impact
l'effet du plan de relance puisque j'ai
bien regardé le document qui nous est
parvenu l'a dit c'est plus la
présentation d'appeler d'un plan de
relance que d'apple est d'ailleurs et
avec un effet que le gouvernement estime
sur l'activité à 1,1 point de pib et il
a à cet égard deux incertitudes vous
notez que votre avis notre avis que la
mise en oeuvre de ce plan de relance
pourrait être plus lente que prévu c'est
un des sujets à une question que nous
avons collectivement posées au
gouvernement lorsqu'il est venu dans
cette séance on peut afficher un beau
plan de relance à 100 milliards d'euros
mais quand on connaît la capacité des
administrations françaises recrée des
procédures et donc la question de la
certitude quant aux décaissements
c'est une première et donc elle est au
calendrier mise en oeuvre une vraie
question
donc je partage cette préoccupation mais
il ya deuxième incertitude qui est tout
simplement celle de l'effet
multiplicateur du plan de relance c'est
un sujet qui n'est pas abordée me semble
t'il dans la vie quels effets
multiplicateurs et donc l'hypothèse que
retenu le gouvernement à la matière vous
parait-elle crédible donc première
question quid de délais de mise en
oeuvre et de l'effet multiplicateur du
plan de relance
ma deuxième question portera vous l'avez
abordé également sur
la tête en ce moment c'est vrai j'étais
comme un certain nombre d'entre vous de
moins en moins nombreux d'ailleurs ici
mais dans cette commission la crise de
2008-2009 qu'évidemment nature tout à
fait différente en 2008 2009 c'était une
crise de liquidités aujourd'hui il n'y a
pas de problème de liquidité au
contraire nous empruntons à des taux
négatif -0 2% et le gouvernement prévoit
une remontée des taux d'intérêt plus 0,7
et cette remontée plus des recettes de
en 2021 et un peu à contrecoeur et
autres contrario pardon de ce que
prévoient les autres pays européens est
ce que c'est pas ça ne paraît pas
pessimiste est ce que dans ce cas là est
ce que ça ne donnerait pas en quelque
sorte des marges de manoeuvre plusieurs
fois on a eu cette présentation qui
consiste être un peu plus pessimiste que
le consensus des économistes
et ça permettait ensuite dans
l'exécution d'avoir rassemble de marge
de manoeuvre
donc question donc sur les taux et ma
troisième question porte sur votre
conclusion est que vous avez rappelé
très justement en disant je le cite que
vous indiquez que la soutenabilité à
moyen terme des finances publiques à
l'appel à la plus grande vigilance pour
que sur tous les bancs on ne peut que
partager de cette commission des
finances on peut que partager
évidemment cet avis est donc la question
qui se pose c'est après le plan de
relance quid du calendrier de la
consolidation budgétaire
bah je crois qu'on était un certain
nombre rencontrer des élus dans une
campagne sénatoriale et chaque fois on
parlait de la situation économique c'est
quand rembourser cette dette quand
commenceront nous a remboursé ou du
moins quand arrivons-nous à une
consolidation budgétaire choix que
promettre une nouvelle règle de
recevabilité budgétaire monsieur le
président tout amendement d'un mois d'un
milliard d'euros n'est pas recevable
parce que là ça peut ça en ce moment on
était chaque année discuter de 500 euros
1000 euros dix mille euros que en haute
finance on a l'impression qu'on est n'a
changé totalement de monde et donc
supposer qu'on a aidé en ce moment ce
serait évidemment très difficile de dire
quelle rigueur budgétaire ou même
veiller à ne pas dépenser je pense que
ayant nous sommes
de la relance ou dans le soutien à
l'activité économique peut-être même pas
encore de la relance et de l'osm osera
un jour le temps de la consolidation
budgétaire afin de reconstituer des
marges de manoeuvre est-ce que vous
pouvez nous éclairer sur le calendrier
qui pourrait être le point déclencheur
du moment où on devrait commencer cette
consultation est ce que ça veut dire
concrètement qu'il faut qu'on ait un
redressement des comptes publics dès que
le pib retrouvé par une aux niveaux 2019
même avec un écart de production négatif
qu allez-vous après pour vous le moment
où il faut peut-être en clair revenir à
un monde plus plus réel plus normal elle
normale en tout cas celui où on n'est
plus dans le vert turdidés simplement
des vannes budgétaires mais dans celui
de la consolidation
merci général mes chers collègues chez
sept inscrits pour le moment huit toiles
a donc nous allons débuter
peut-être fera une petite césure pour
que puis lorsqu'il ci puisse déjà réagir
mais je vous propose d'entendre tout
d'abord claude raynal la première
inscrit bonjour à tous ce dont je me
suis le président oui je suis d'accord
avec albéric de montgolfier pour dire
que
l'exercice est difficile j'allais dire
tous les exercices aujourd'hui en
finances publiques sont difficiles faire
un plf c'est difficile donner un avis du
haut conseil sur ce plf c'est dangereux
tout casser à risque
donc on salue la tentative mais en même
temps sur le projet de loi de finances
moi très sincèrement je m'attendais à
avoir un projet avec un chiffrage une
étude médiane et puis peut-être un
encadrement par une solution plus
difficile d'une solution plus optimiste
mais je pense que je m'attendais pas
vraiment à voir un plf qui soit aussi
haut aussi carrée que d'habitude quoi si
je puis dire celui-là les circonstances
je pense que l'on pouvait s'attendre à
avoir quelque chose d'un peu plus avec
un faisceau dans lequel on essaierait de
bâtir quelque chose et avec évidemment
un scénario de base dans ce faisceau
donc je voulais avoir votre avis là
dessus et avec l'idée que si on
bâtissait un faisceau il y avait
peut-être une relecture à faire dans six
mois qui se fera peut-être d'ailleurs
dans tout et en tout état de cause et
qui nous permettait peut-être d'encadrer
la discussion et l'ensemble des risques
parce que là on a on a du mal à savoir
pourquoi on prend tel niveau tu es
plutôt que tel autre
sur l'ensemble des éléments qui
constituent généralement les le calcul
des recettes et des dépenses du plf et
surtout le calcul des recettes en
réalité deuxième question pour vous
réinterroger sur changer de loi de
programmation
on a bien compris qu'elle était caduque
ça c'est clair
mais faut-il vraiment se relancer dans
un exercice de loi de programmation
d'ici quelques mois et finalement ne
faut-il pas mieux attendre la fin de la
pandémie d'une certaine façon ou de la
crise sanitaire parce qu' est-ce qu'on
va pas la réécrire pour rien ou une fois
de plus c'est de cette loi de
programmation
donc pourquoi une telle urgence selon
vous c'est ma question
sylvie vermeillet puis germes de chair
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président je reviens sur la page 5 de
votre présentation avec le rebond de la
racine carrée que vous avez présenté et
les donc le rebond des différents pays
européens
j'aimerais savoir s'il ya une
corrélation entre la force des plans de
relance et le rebond que vous exposer
comment est ce que vous avez construit
votre prévision est en tout cas est ce
que on n'a pas forcément l'impression
parce que quand on regarde le l'espagne
où le rebond
voilà je voudrais savoir s'il ya une
corrélation si vous avez baser votre
votre estimation sur sur ce facteur là
merci se susurre cost merci monsieur le
président j'ai à vos trois projets trois
questions d'efficacité ce président
l'efficacité du plan de relance sur la
croissance et albéric de montgolfier
viens d'en parler
les étals estime à 1,1 pour cent de
croissance en plus bien effectivement
j'ai cru comprendre que historiquement
les plans de relance fonctionnent est
lorsqu'il y avait des réformes de
structure elle est à tout le moins des
réformes structurelles dans les
ministères pour dépenser et dans les
collectivités locales pour dépenser car
j'ai cru comprendre notamment et vous
l'avez dit vous-même su président que
les collectivités locales n'était pour
les conseils départementaux les conseils
régionaux qui investissent de temps en
temps un peu d'argent n'étaient pas été
en élection était sans doute moins
disposés vu que le gouvernement n'avait
pas retenu cette hypothèse de passer par
eux pour faire distribuer l'hélicoptère
abonnés et inventé cette fois-ci par le
gouvernement donc j'ai un problème
est-ce que vous
ne croyez pas qu'il manque quelque chose
pour faciliter la dépense et la centaine
de milliards avancés à dépenser en 18
mois seulement qui dit mieux
autre sujet l'efficacité de la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
je ne suis pas d'accord avec vous
monsieur le président vous me permettrez
lorsque vous avez dit que la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
était caduc à partir de 2020 a été cadic
l'année d'après l'année d'après le
gouvernement s'est empressé dé juste
après pardon l'avoir fait voter de ne
pas la respecter
c'est le premier gouvernement qui votent
une loi pour se mettre tout seul hors la
loi et continuer à franchir allègrement
allègrement toutes les frontières de
cette loi de programmation des finances
publiques qui l'a vraiment plus rien à
voir dès l'année suivante et ainsi de
suite
à chaque fois qu aux gilets jaunes je
vais vous en d1 et des autres aux après
réforme des retraites qu'ovide il ya
toujours une bonne raison pour ne pas
respecter la règle alors du coup la
question de l'efficacité le sujet de la
dette
ne croyez vous pas que la vraie
efficacité ne serait pas avec votre
progression et force publique mais une
vraie règle d'or comme on a si souvent
parler si j'avais accepté
[Applaudissements]
monsieur président peut être vous
inviter à répondre à cette première
série ce les questions du rapporteur
général bien sûr celle de notre premier
collègues
en effet monsieur le rapporteur général
a raison je n'ai pas totalement oublié
d'autres activités donc je suis aussi
venu plaider la pour un programme mais
vous savez où vous ne savez pas ces avis
que nous produisons qui sont je pense
d'une remarquable qualité sont faits
avec deux équivalents temps plein
deuxième chose
donc des gens qui travaillent jour et
nuit pour faire ça je fut rapporteur
spécial mais donnons donc j'ai obtenu du
ministre du budget que je remercie
d'ailleurs cet égard d'avoir cinq
équivalents temps plein en plus donc
c'est pas les amendements un milliard
c'est mais ça veut dire quand même plus
été rapporteur spécial plus d'un
triplement des moyens ça permettra je
pense de faire des choses plus diverses
a commencé mais ça prend tout son sens
si on a aussi largement du mandat je
vais commencer et c'est la question que
plusieurs d'entre vous m'ont posé en
fait sur le sur les l'impact du plan de
relance
nous ne disons pas que les 1,1 point qui
est sont prévues par le g en 2021 ne
sont pas crédibles
ils sont crédibles mais volontariste
pourquoi essentiellement monsieur le
président du fait que en effet les
décaissements
c'était aussi une question qui est posée
une question d'âge et néry nous
connaissons notre pays me coller sur la
façon dont les les plans descendent
jusqu'au terrain il faut en effet mettre
en place une ingénierie qui permette non
pas de dépenser 100 milliards en 18 mois
comme ça je pense que nous verrons je ne
prétends pas lui-même mais de dépenser
les milliards qui sont prévus dans le
cadre du plf pour 2021 et là en effet
nous pensons que à la fois du fait de la
saturation déjà de certaines capacités
sectorielles et des difficultés
traditionnelles à mettre en oeuvre ses
investissements disons-le hypothèses et
volontariste pour ce qui est de l'effet
multiplicateur est un sujet dont nous
avons longuement débattu dans les
auditions ils les 2 08 nous ne pensons
pas que ce soit multipliée taux élevé au
regard de la pression d'économistes donc
c'est essentiellement comme le premier
facteur qui explique que nous estimons
qu'il ya un volontarisme sans pour
autant qu'il soit impossible d'avoir un
tir de l'un point souhaitons le mais il
ça pourrait être un petit peu moins tout
notre jugement sur 2021 comme étant un
peu volontariste sur les taux d'intérêt
là le hcf p relève la prudence
traditionnelle du gouvernement sur
l'hypothèse de taux en effet
ça peut avoir quelques avantages garde
telles que marge de manoeuvre mais si on
regarde le consensus des économistes et
la prévision de taux du gouvernement il
est comme mon écart dans le consensus
c'est zéro pour l'année prochaine pour
la zone euro et dans la preview vraiment
c'est 0,7
donc là encore c'est pas impossible mais
c'est pas non plus le plus probable pas
probable que les taux d'intérêt se
relève de 0,7 point en 2021 au regard de
l'analyse du haut conseil des finances
publiques donc il a effectivement il ya
non pas une cagnotte mais une marge de
manoeuvre qui est possible sur la dette
la conciliation budgétaire vous savez
j'ai auquel mandat du haut conseil stade
et bac entre nous nous avons eu ça aussi
nous trouvions pas parler de la tête je
ne concevais pas que nous ne parlions
pas qu'elle commande du haut conseil
soutenait que nous étions là à la limite
de notre mandat je pense que nous sommes
en plein dedans mais j'aimerais pouvoir
répondre à votre question en allant un
peu plus loin je ne le peux pas dans le
cas du mandat puisque je suis déjà à mes
limites
donc je suis pas capable de vous
répondre quand seule chose que je peux
dire c'est peut-être de réflexion qui
sont de bon sens c'est la première c'est
que et ça c'est plus le message de la
cour ou du conseil dans la situation que
nous connaissons une situation de crise
sanitaire mais aussi de suture crise
économique et sociale
nous ne contestons pas la légitimité de
donner la priorité à la relance
la priorité au soutien à l'économie mais
nous attirons l'attention sur le fait
que pour autant on ne peut pas ignorer
la question de la dette et qu'à un
moment donné il faudra retrouver une
trajectoire de soutenabilité d'aidé
publique en sa c'est un débat sur lequel
j'aimerais que nous puissions poursuivre
nous échanger ça n'est pas aussi de
l'élargissement du mandat du haut
conseil
je suis pas en jeu pour avoir une
réponse personnelle ne serait pas de
grand intérêt
il s'agit pas de ça donc je dirais
priorité la dépense
compte tenu de la situation mais ne pas
oublier été vigilants sur la question de
la soutenabilité à moyen terme de la
dette publique
je ne n'ai pas de commentaire sur
les la manière dont sont élaborés les
projets de loi de finances
ce qu'il fallait faire des scénarios
notons que la masse il a certes été très
élevé qu elle même est difficilement
quantifiable ce qu'il ya faire autant de
beylev que deux scénarios de croissance
ghosn n'a pas choisi on vous présente
mais ce qui est clair c'est que il faut
noter l'incertitude bien sûr elles
demeurent et qu'il n'est pas interdit
que dans des bas cette question soit
évoquée sur la programmation des
finances publiques c'est une question
qui est qui est posée aussi sur le
sénateur bon il ya il ya plusieurs
approches possibles
on peut en effet attendre la fin de la
crise sanitaire ou que tout ça soit
largement derrière nous on peut attendre
la fin de la crise économique et sociale
je dirais que ce qui résume le mieux
notre message c'est aussi tôt que
possible aux stocks possible c'est le
plus tôt possible
pardon d'être sur cette lapalissade et
nous pensons que le plus tôt possible
ça devrait être sauf évidemment
dégradation très forte instabilité
persistante le printemps 2021 pourquoi
parce que je me prononce pas sur quel
moment là le prague la nation est devenu
caduc jeudi gras qu'elle est muni
caduque maintenant pour avoir été moi
même ministre des finances et pour avoir
connu une vie politique avant avoir été
parlementaire membre de la commission
des finances de l'assemblée nationale
dieu plusieurs lois de finances et il ya
toujours eu des écarts là nous ne sommes
plus dans les cars nous sommes dans
laquelle lui citer ce qui est assez
différent parce que la situation de
crise rend les choses et on peut pas le
reprocher à ce gouvernement pas plus que
d'autres auparavant en les choses
totalement de ces têtes imprévisible
donc quand on est un événement
extraordinaire on ne peut pas garder la
même boussole ou la même encre que de ce
point de vue là je souligne monsieur le
sénateur monsieur rénale c'est compliqué
de vivre sur loi de programmation
réaliste parce qu'on peut porter aucun
jugement
notre programme de organique n'est pas
respectée
même le regard européen devient
compliqué toutes les notions sur
lesquels nous travaillons croissance
potentielle et seule structure elles
deviennent hors de rapport avec la
moindre réalité c'est pour ça que je
maintienne quand même le plus tôt
possible
d'autant que c'est quelque chose qui
nous aura pas échappé aux autres c'est
le cycle politique
si c'est pas le printemps 2021 ça risque
d'être comme on dire beaucoup plus tard
est beaucoup plus tard c'est trop tard
c'est vrai nous ne pouvons pas vivre
totalement sans règle je ne dis pas
qu'elle règle mais avoir n'avoir aucun
point de repère solide c'est toujours
fâcheux pour le débat démocratique voilà
la raison pour laquelle si c'est
possible si disons la situation est
stabilisée lisible au printemps il
paraît raisonnable que ce soit le moment
que nous visions sur la question des
prévisions à crolles comics qui figurent
la madame la sénatrice tout simplement
ce qu'on appelle consensus pour casser
le c le consensus des économistes
on voit c'est vrai que la courbe est
partout la même mais malgré tout chez
certains ont descendu plus bas on
remonte un peu plus haut
et quand on prend les conséquences de sa
en termes de croissance et d'emploi ça
n'est pas totalement négligeable parce
que même si le profil elle-même vous
voyez quand même sur ce graphique
il ya quelques différences qui ne sont
pas totalement insignifiante
enfin je crois avoir répondu au passage
votre question monsieur le sénateur
alors sur la règle d'or
là je suis au delà tout à fait de mes
compétences pour le moment nous avons
une loi organique
c'est peu organique prévoit des lois de
programmation tant qu'on reste dans
cette loi organique
il faut modifier notre programmation
mais on peut aussi envisager mais ça ça
n'est pas du tout dans mon rôle
une autre loi organique ça devient quand
même beaucoup plus lourd et ça ça
appartient au débat politique et public
peut-être pour d'autres échéances je
serai encore là mais lorsqu'elle je ne
participerai pas avec ma casquette de
président de la cour des comptes
donc dans le cadre qui est le nôtre
actuellement ces lois de programmation
qu'il faut modifier
je pense qu'il est logique de
fonctionner pour le moment un cadre
changer donc dans un premier temps en
tout cas c'est ce débat qui s'était déjà
posée en 2012 je me souviens puisque
certains proposaient une règle d'or mais
vous savez la châtaigne le bio tout à
fait personnelle quand même quand on
regarde les règles d'or y compris dans
certains pays où il existe je pense aux
l'allemagne quand survient un événement
comme celui-ci ne tiennent pas
donc c'est comme la programmation qui
s'impose davantage mais je suis allé
trop loin chez ben je me tais merci
monsieur le président on reprend les
interventions avec bernard delcros plus
jeune fils louis merci monsieur présent
j'avais une ou deux questions concernant
la vie des collectivités quels
prévisions peut-on faire sur le niveau
d'investissement des collectivités en
2021 et sur les pertes de recettes pour
les collectivités lié évidemment à la
situation la situation que l'on connaît
et puis troisième question sur la baisse
et des impôts de production qui a été
annoncé par le gouverneur et sur les
modalités de compensation aux
collectivités merci bernard jean bizet
quel symbole délit merci monsieur le
président monsieur le président du haut
conseil
ma question s'adresse à vous même mais
aussi l'ancien commissaire à l'ancien
ministre des finances pour vous rappeler
que le
le prêt mutualiser le prêt européen et
qui est au coeur du plan de relance
la france représente 15% du piment et sa
population est légèrement supérieure
entre 15 et 20%
mais la france va récupérer simplement 8
% du prêt de l'union mais vend
rembourser 10 7%
c'est la logique de la mutualisation et
on ne peut que se réjouir de l'action du
couple franco allemand
ceci étant dit ça suppose à mon avis moi
j'ai deux conclusions la première va
falloir être extrêmement vigilant ce qui
concerne la reprise de la compétitivité
je dirais de notre pays ça suppose
ça suppose une baisse drastique des
dépenses publiques
encore une fois on n'a pas été assez je
dirais volontariste en la matière et la
deuxième chose dont je ne vous ai pas
entendu mais encore une fois c'est
plutôt un ancien commissaire que je
m'adresse là il va falloir
impérativement que politiquement on soit
très exigeant en matière de ressources
propres de l'union ce sera autant je
dirais de participation nationale aux
piles de l'union - et là quand on sait
que l'europe apporte souvent les bonnes
réponses b à son temps à son riz et bien
il y a malgré tout urgence
et il est urgent sur ses ressources
propres je sens une partie de bras de
fer se mener entre le parlement européen
et la commission est très honnêtement je
trouve que je suis du côté plutôt delà
du parlement européen là-dessus qui est
extrêmement volontariste sur les
ressources propres
j'en entends pas assez parlé au niveau
national merci merci jean pascal
savoldelli puis christine lagarde
merci monsieur le président pour votre
pour votre présentation vous avez évoqué
la question de la soutenabilité de la
dette publique
et puis il ya cette question qu est g a
fait l'objet d'interrogations sur rebond
de l'activité
donc je vous livrais deux questions et
tu es un petit diagnostic je vais
commencer un peu par le diagnostic est
ce qu'il est partagé ou pas moi je vous
dit que vous nous dites le rebond j'ai
regardé ce qui se passe du point de vue
nos entreprises françaises on a un taux
d'investissement à même niveau
donc là on pourrait être assuré on a un
petit problème l'autofinancement
s'effondrent de 40 points et les marches
de cette fois donc on l'a quand même un
indicateur est quand même à prendre en
compte
et pourquoi je vous dis ça parce que un
sujet qui vient rarement ici donc je
comprends du point de vos prérogatives
insincérité cohérence européenne
moi je voudrais attirer votre attention
sur la question de la dette privée parce
que dans un moment où on aide et ont
contribué à essayer d'accompagner les
entreprises dans leurs difficultés
moi je voudrais vous interrogez jusqu'à
quand on va où qu'on va t'on vraiment se
poser la question de la soutenabilité de
la dette privée parce que monsieur le
président du haut conseil
si je regarde bien son nom parle jamais
mais la dette privée c'est 138,20 % du
pib et on parle d'une tendance à 150 %
pour la france alors que dans la zone
euro
nous on a une augmentation de 6,4 et la
zone euro ces 2 1%
ce que je veux vous dire et avoir votre
votre éclairage ya pas de papiers collés
et d'effets mécaniques entre dette
privée et aides publiques mais y'a pas
mon souhait on s'ignore pas l'une
n'ignore pas l'hôte les mécanismes de la
loi de finances
donc je voulais avoir votre avis
là-dessus dernière chose c'est sur la
question si je vous dit si je me trompe
mais j'ai vu qu'il y aurait une
prévision beylev pour 2021 une
diminution de l'investissement public
local en 2020 de 4,9 milliards en 2020
par rapport à 2019
et là nous tous je crois que nous sommes
tous rassemblés là dessus quand dans
notre pays il y as baisse de
l'investissement public local ça des
conséquences notamment sur le tissu tpe
pme et il serait plus marquée dans le
pfr 3 - 2 4 milliards d'euros dont je
finis mon propos et savoir si vous avez
une explication
comment on doit expliquer cette
rétractation doublement supérieur aux
prévisions puisque c'est pas les
prévisions papa le haut conseil
mais c'est pas les prévisions que nous
avait donné le gouvernement dans la
succession doit rappeler c'est vrai que
c'est assez inédit et les faire un peu
les faire 2 pdf r3 donc voilà je vous
avoue que ça ça fait partie de mes
préoccupations
merci merci monsieur le président alors
je voulais vous interroger sur la dette
publique mais j'ai compris qu'on était à
la limite de vos prérogatives en tant
que président du conseil donc je prépare
ma question vous pourrez certainement
répondre quand vous viendrez nous
présenter le rapport sur l'évolution des
finances publiques locales puisque
aujourd'hui on a lu un peu partout des
sujets sur l'évolution de la dette
partie sécurité sociale comptes sociaux
la dette de l'état mais qu'en est il en
fait des autres dettes donc les
établissements publics
et puis la dette des collectivités et
est elle soutenable
et si ce n'est pas le cas pour lesquels
catégorie de collectivité va se trouver
vraiment proche du mur a une échéance à
une échéance certaines donc ça c'était
ma première question mais du coup je
vous dirai rien
après sainte foy et mal et je voudrais
rebondir toujours sur cette histoire de
rebond donc vous nous avez dit que les
courbes et est issu du consensus
forecast
on entend pareil parler uniquement des
aléas liés à l'évolution de la crise
sanitaire
mais les années antérieures on parlait
d'autre type d'aléas notamment la guerre
commerciale où les enjeux géopolitiques
il me semble qu'ils n'ont pas disparu
dans le monde de 2021
donc j'aimerais savoir dans quelle
mesure il influe aussi sur la
trajectoire de ce consensus
merci christine n'est plus d'inscrits
chef président ainsi que le président
fait messieurs les présidents chers
collègues tout d'abord le président vous
avez évoqué l' indépendance et en
entendant ces propos mais venus en
mémoire un article de jean denis bredin
sur l'indépendance de la justice au
moment où je suis devenu magistrat et ce
qui m'a beaucoup inspiré en tout cas
questionner tout au long de mon activité
professionnelle c'est parler
d'indépendance bien de la justice et pas
simplement par rapport au pouvoir ou
pouvoir politique en particulier mais
parler de l'indépendance par rapport à
soi même par rapport à son cadre
intellectuel ces schémas de pensée et
parfois c'est a priori donc j'avais
envie avant d'échanger en tout cas de
faire partager ce souvenir avec
l'ensemble des collègues présents dans
cette salle et avec eux vous même de
deux éléments de deux questions en
particulier on vous parlait de rebond en
racine carrée mon entend beaucoup parler
de rebond en cas on évoque donc les
finances publiques pas simplement pour
les finances publiques elles-mêmes et
pour ses effets sur les entreprises les
ménages en fait les différentes
catégories d'agents économiques et donc
il semblerait que ce rebond en cas ne
conduise à 9,20 ne permettent pas aux
plus modestes d'entre nous de bénéficier
de cette reprise donc jeu
à voir savoir si c'est votre quel est
votre avis et si vous avez dans le cadre
de votre périmètre d'intervention
possible enfin j'aimerais effectivement
connaître avoir votre éclairage
s'agissant de la notation de la dette
vous savez et dit attention
effectivement parce que c'est un sujet
qui est évoqué par des économistes et
par les plus éminents d'entre eux sur la
question de l'annulation d'une partie en
tout cas la dette vous avez dit
attention il ya des épargnants mais
souffre que la dt et tu pars à peu près
en quart la dette par la banque de la
banque centrale européenne et par les
banques centrales
elle-même est donc cette caractéristique
particulière des défenseurs des
détenteurs pardon de la dette mérite
peut-être qu'on eu une approche un peu
plus complète un peu plus fine du sujet
là aussi je serais intéressé par avoir
votre avis merci première cette question
y at il une corrélation entre les plans
de relance et le rebond
je tiens à préciser encore une fois de
choses dans les limites du mandat au
conseil les finances publiques que ce ne
sont pas nos prévisions mixo sont celles
du consensus des économistes
nous n'avons pas analysé les plans de
relance de nos partenaires c'est
difficile dans le temps imparti avec les
moyens qui sont les nôtres
j'espère que nous ferons mieux dans
l'avenir pour le coup même mandat
constant avec nos propres moyens mais
incontestablement une corrélation entre
l'ampleur du rebond et l'ampleur de la
perte initiale ce qui est d'ailleurs une
des raisons pour lesquelles si nous
jugeons que la séquence 2020 2021 est
plausible
le séquençage lui même nous paraît tout
petit peu différent parce que bien en
plus vous baissez en 2020 plus vous
pouvez rebondir en 2021 disons que les
autres d'instituts de sondages plutôt
les autres instituts de économiques
estiment en général que
on devrait baisser un peu moins en 2020
et rebondir du coup un peu moins en 2021
ce qui aboutit grosso modo aux mêmes
résultats
plusieurs questions portent sur
l'investissement local le gouvernement
prévoit là dessus à 1 rebonds nets en
2021 de +7 9% alors qu'il y ait eu c'est
vrai best l'investissement 2020 qui
provient d'abord de la crise sanitaire
disons tout ça est un peu mécanique
parce que des chantiers ont dû être
arrêtées au printemps et donc la base de
2020 sera particulier basse là encore on
trouve le même mécanisme du sang des
recettes et vous le savez les recettes
politiques légales sont à court terme
moins sensibles au cycle que les
recettes de l'état et donc chute moins
brutalement que l'ensemble mais j'aurai
l'occasion de revenir devant vous pour
parler en effet des finances publiques
locales dans leur ensemble ça je le
ferai dans le cadre de travaux la cour
des comptes sur les finances publiques
locales prochainement pour ce qui est
des questions du sénateur bizet sur
l'europe
bon j'ai bien pris au jeu connaît les
différents facteurs que vous évoquez je
n'ai jamais été pour ma part partisan de
la théorie du juste retour mais je
serais plutôt un partisan de la théorie
du retour efficace c'est à dire que ce
que nous devons faire parce qu'il ya
certes mais aussi sur la partie
européenne du plan de relance puisque on
escompte qui contribuent en tout cas
cette partie contenue à peu près 40% des
ressources du plan de relance
encore faut-il d'abord qu'il y ait un
accord sur le plan de relance et il faut
ensuite que quand une fois cet argent
puisse redescendre
est ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure est
ce que vous avez dit sur la tuyauterie
l'ingénierie la mise en place de
mécanismes qui permettent d'avoir des
investissements efficaces
c'est indispensable de même que très
clairement un des objectifs du plan de
relance pour le relancer à la fois un
plan d'urgence mais c'est aussi un plan
de structure c'est d'améliorer la
compétitivité de l'économie de mener ans
à terme ça tombe de réforme mais aussi
de mettre en place des investissements
dans de nouveaux secteurs économiques de
revoir sectoriellement être commis c'est
ce qu'on appelle parfois le retour à la
souveraineté donc tout ça au site
exigera de notre part à tous une très
grande vigilance
pour ce qui est des ressources propres
je partage totalement votre sentiment là
puisque vous vous appelez à jean une
casquette je le fais une seconde on a
augmenté le plafond des ressources
propres de 1 à 2%
parallèlement à la mise en place du plan
de relance européen
c'est une question qui ne peut pas être
négligé et de ce point de vue là c'est
vrai que il ya un certain nombre de
pistes qui sont évoqués dans son abord
taxe carbone aux frontières pour soi
aussi la taxe sur le numérique
pour ma part je me suis rendu la semaine
dernière à la commission de bruxelles et
j'ai rencontré le président du parlement
européen
à cette occasion bon c'est vrai qu'un
traditionnel plus grand volontarisme du
parlement mais j'ai pas senti la
commission honnêtement de la main je
pense que le débat principal sera au
conseil entre les états membres
parce que là il ya évidemment des
positions très différentes l'ancien
commissaire la fiscalité que je suis qui
a notamment proposé une directive sur le
numérique sait de quoi il s'agit
puisqu'à la fin j'ai réussi à obtenir le
consentement de 24 états membres mais
quatre ont bloqué ce qui posait aussi la
question sur les ressources propres de
la décision au vote à la majorité
qualifiée dans l'europe telle qu'elle
est c'est un problème qui se pose nous
les vous m'entraîner là sur mon péché
mignon
je m'arrête tout de suite j'aurais quand
même ajouté une réponse à une question
que vous ne posez pas mais qui est
implicitement soutenu
suscité par la même voie là c'est la
question des règles mais elle est
sérieuse c'est la section des règles de
finances publiques
de la même façon que j'appelais nouvelle
loi de programmation il me paraît clair
ne couperont pas à une révision des
règles de finances publiques européennes
dans la mesure où là aussi on observe
certains points de caducité on ne peut
pas rester sans règles
on peut pas suspendre pour l'éternité
les règles on peut pas revenir
exactement aux critères antérieures
parce que nous serons une fibre très
différentes
la cour des comptes dans son rapport sur
la situation et les perspectives des
finances publiques estimait que nous
allions vivre très durablement avec plus
de 100 % des pluies que jusqu'en 2030
que le déficit public ne reviendrait pas
en dessous de 4% de 3% avant cinq ans ah
bon on peut toujours dire ok on met le
coup de patin on freine tout mais ce
serait totalement contraire à l'exigence
de relance de la croissance donc il faut
bien avoir des règles qui soient plus
lisibles plus simple plus cohérente et
ça je crois que c'est une réflexion qui
est devant nous qui est éminemment
politique et à la commission et au
parlement et au conseil
il y aura des débats importants mais où
on a besoin de règles il faut pas que ce
soit exactement les mêmes ja il faut une
révision intelligent que ces règles
pardonnez moi de passer ce message qui
était aussi celui de cour des comptes
dans son rapport et qui est
implicitement contenue dans le rapport
vous conseille des finances publiques
vient implicitement sur la dette privée
sur le sénateur j'adorerais vous
répondre mais là je suis totalement
démunis
tant que président du conseil
scientifique je dirais simplement que
évidemment c'est fait raison sur le fait
que c'est un facteur économique qui est
à prendre en compte de manière massive
de même façon que la sénatrice je
reviendrai en effet vous parlez la dette
des collectivités locales je souhaite
que nous l'amélioration du mandat du
haut conseil lui permet de faire une
analyse plus profonde de la dette et de
sa soutenabilité sur votre 2ème partie
de questions je suis entièrement
d'accord avec vous les incertitudes
géopolitiques ne n'ont pas disparu
la première d'entre elle tenant aux
résultats l'élection américaine et ce
soir nous aurons le premier débat entre
monsieur kaisen et monsieur trump c'est
mentionné dans l'avis du haut conseil
comme dans les prévisions et donc vous
avez entièrement raison là dessus il n'y
a pas que la crise sanitaire le monde
dans lequel nous vivons est un monde la
tendance à l'entropie et plus en plus
grand du choc entre puissance et ça
soulève pour l'europe une question c'est
est-ce que nous allons rester l'agneau
chez les loups et ça c'est une question
qui est aussi en dehors de membres enfin
pour ce qui est du rebond cas oui ça
nous incite quand même à réfléchir
sectoriellement et je ferai de réflexion
à cet égard la première c'est que quelle
que soit la passe que vous ayez tu n'as
pas compter sur des nuances mais dix
huit ou neuf sets
au final on est quand même dans un cas
de plausibilité avec en plus une très
grande incertitude
mais les secteurs certains secteurs vont
être très durement touchés sont déjà on
pense à tout ce qui est transports tu es
transport aérien
on se pense à tout ce qui est tourisme
on pense à tout ce qui est côté louis
restauration et la deuxième réflexion
elles portent sur l'emploi car même avec
une croissance qui revient à soho avec 1
pile qui reviendra l'ami 2022 à son
niveau de 2000 19/01/2009 nous n'auront
évidemment pas le même contenu enfin la
croissance donc il ya des modifications
structurelles
ce qui veut dire que en effet quand on
parle
deux courbes en cas il faut prêter une
attention très grande à ce qui se passe
sectoriellement et ne pas se noyer dans
la macroéconomie mais aussi passé à la
microéconomie ce qui encore une fois
n'est pas le mandat du conseil finances
publiques vous avez entièrement raison
là on parle prévisions macroéconomiques
après quand on va regarder ou soulever
le capot d'ailleurs la plupart des
conjoncturistes que nous avons consultés
évoqué bien cette discordance entre une
croissance qui parce que finalement
savez on sera descendu beaucoup plus bas
on sera remonté beaucoup plus vite que
par la crise de 2008
nous n'avons retrouvé dans l'union
européenne la zone euro le niveau de
pipe de 2008 qu'en 2006 les choses se
passent comme ça non mais là je raisonne
par rapport à des prévisions nous avons
estimé nous même plausible
nous aurions retrouver le niveau de pipe
de 2019 plus vite que nous n'avons
retrouvé le niveau de pipe de près de
1800 oui six ans pour le faire nous
mettrions deux ans oui mais l'impact
c'est auriel est l'impact en termes de
croissance de l'emploi lui peut-être
extrêmement différents ce qui veut dire
que ça implique des réflexions très
profonde
là dessus est très complexe